[Music]
do you do anything because you bring up
a good point driving in this town people
get very stressed they get very do you
do anything to calm yourself down when
you're in the car
i do i like to listen to books on tape
yeah i do that too especially i've been
kind of on an autobiography kick lately
and my uh my babysitter ellen was over
the other day and so she shares her
library's books with me sometimes and
she was handing me this box of the cds
and she just had this look on her face
like she had been through something
and she was gonna make me go through it
too
and i looked down and it was uh the
mackenzie phillips book do you remember
when that was out oh her autobiography
yeah she was on oprah about it it's all
about her like being on drugs and
sleeping with their dad and stuff yeah
so i just took it i know and i could not
stop listening to it i listened to it
for like three days straight in my car
and my kid was like in the back seat i
just threw him some crackers
i said and he's like mom i'm thirsty i'm
like please she's getting to the part
where she starts freebasing be quiet i
need to hear this
she's like mommy
yeah i could not put it down
she's like but mom i said her dad is
coming on to her oh come on
too much god too much not enough too
much
um
well what about something well you
shouldn't be listening to those tapes to
calm yourself down you just shouldn't be
what have you tried to
have you tried anything else have you
tried a lot of people in this town they
meditate have you tried that i did
really i took the transcendental
meditation course oh i haven't done that
what's it like well
you can do it right now it's pretty easy
just close your eyes
right now yeah okay that's all i thought
there was a hole okay
just
breathe yeah i'm doing that you're doing
it
don't talk
how do you feel happier
you feel more whole no i i i just felt
like i'm on television
an audience here pretty cool huh
there's a fake moon over there
see you're becoming more aware already
i'm very aware of my space is that what
happens is that really do i mean i'm
serious i don't know anything about
meditation is that something that you
get well i'd the one thing i got from it
i went to this potluck dinner with other
meditators a very quiet dinner not a lot
of people
people everyone was in their own space
just quietly eating
but i met an abundance whisperer there
no idea what that is an abundance
whisperer yes she comes into your house
and even if your house is really clean
she'll feel where the clutter is that's
blocking you from the abundance that's
coming into your life conan
is that true yes you're being honest i
am being honest have you guys heard of
this an abundance whisperer i've heard
of plenty of horseshit but uh
[Applause]
so she tells you
she comes in and she tells you even if
your house looks it's like you're a
hoarder too many forks do you use that
many forks i'm like no i don't so i
threw them away and now i only eat off
the spoons right
it's amazing
my guess is you know what it sounds like
to me that she goes through and she
finds something of value i was like this
is blocking
your good energy
i need this this gold egg
i'm taking this away you know what i
mean
do you have a gold egg in your house i
have a gold egg yeah
no one's getting my gold
he actually has one that he sleeps in
yeah i get inside my gold egg and go to
sleep what am i a leprechaun no i don't
have a gold egg you're only you're only
supposed to keep things that you
uh love or you need and if you don't
love it and you don't need it get rid of
it like there was a guy at the dinner
who had uh storage space and he started
talking and she was like oh god that's
like she just turned pale that's the
worst thing you can have is like a
storage space that's outside of you you
don't know what's in there you don't
care about it but how does that hurt
your energy man no it's not what if it's
don't do that face with me
what if it's 35 miles away your storage
space how's that blocking my energy
because it's still your stuff and it's
taking up space and you don't need it so
get rid of it conan
those are my gold eggs in that store
space how many do you have i have 800
gold eggs
you won't be getting my gold eggs is he